[Music]
Hi everyone. I'm Rustin. I'm a product
manager with Google Labs and really
thrilled to be here and get to speak to
you today. This is really like a a dream
come true.
So I'm an engineer at heart. This is my
first compiler, Borland C++ 3.1. It came
in the mail on 10 5 and a half inch
floppy discs. I ordered it from AOL
classifides. It was amazing. This is my
bulletin board. Yeah. That I hosted out
of my parents' closet and salvage
computers. And I just think it's ironic
that when I saw AI come out, I
recognized the textbased interfaces
perfectly from hosting bulletin boards.
And then when I saw this, like many of
you, I dedicated my career to AI coding.
And this is chat GPT 3.5. Isn't it crazy
that we the how slow this is? And this
used to be state-of-the-art only two
years ago. It's pretty amazing.
Right now, I'm a product manager for
Jules. And Jules is an asynchronous
coding agent meant to run in the
background and do all those tasks that
you don't want to do in parallel in the
background. And we launched this just
two weeks ago at IO to everyone
everywhere all at once
for free
while Josh was up on the stage trying to
demo other Google Labs products. And so
he called us. We said, "Oh, we got to
shut it down." so that we can demo other
products and and luckily we got it up
and going. But it was a super exciting
launch and the best part about it is to
see these use cases where this is what
we really want to solve. We want to do
the laundry so to say so that you can
focus on the art of coding. So the next
time Firebase updates their SDK, Jules
can do that for you. Or if you just want
to develop from your phone, Jules can do
that for you. So, in the last two weeks,
we've had 40,000 public commits, and
we're super excited what we can bring to
the open-source world.
So, but as developers, we're meant to
think serially. We take a task from the
queue, we work on it, we go on to the
next one. That's our default workflow.
Today, we'll learn about how to maximize
parallel agents. I'll try a real world
demo and we'll go through a real world
use case and then I'll go through some
best practices we've learned from
watching people use jewels.
So for this parallel process really to
work well, we need to get better with AI
at the beginning and the end of the
workflow. Meaning if it's on me to now I
just have to write a bunch of tasks all
day. That's not fun. And if I'm
reviewing PRs and handling merge messes
at the end of the day, that's not going
to work well either. So luckily, help is
on the way. So for example, AI can
easily work through backlogs, bug
reports to create tasks for you with
you. And then uh at the end of the SDLC,
help is on the way where we can use
critic agents, merging agents that can
bring everything together and make it so
that this this parallel workflow that
we've envisioned can really come
together and not drive us crazy.
Remote agents are uniquely suited for
this. Agents inside of our IDE are
always going to be limited by our
laptop. And when you have these remote
agents in the cloud, essentially agents
as a service, they're infinitely
scalable. They're always connected and
then you can develop from anywhere from
any device.
We've seen two types of parallelism
emerging. This is the type that we
expected, which is multitasking. Oh, I'm
just I have 10 different things on my
backlog. Let's do them all at once and
then we'll merge them together and test
them.
Interestingly, you saw an example of the
second type this morning with Solomon
from Dagger showing how he wanted three
different views of his website at the
same time. This was the emergent
behavior we didn't expect, which is
multiple variations. Essentially, we see
users taking a task, especially if it's
a complex task, and saying, "Try it this
way, try it that way, or give me this
variation to look at, or multiple
variations to look at." And then you can
test and choose. And we can have the
agents test and choose the best ones or
the user can can test and choose.
So for example, we see lots of people
who are working on a front-end task test
and they're in a React app and they're
saying I'm adding drag and drop. Maybe
try it using this library uh the React
be beautiful drag and drop or maybe use
DND kit or maybe try it using the test
first and in this parallel asynchronous
environment you can just spin up
multiple agents at the same time they
can try it they can easily come back
together choose the best one and you're
off to the races. Okay, demo time.
So exit out of this
For a demo, I'm going to use the
conference schedule website.
And
Swix for all his skills, as you can see,
is probably not spend a lot of time
designing the the schedule website, as
you can see there. Anytime there's a
horizontal scroll scroll bar, uh we we
know that's a problem. But luckily, they
knew that and they said, "We're just
going to publish the JSON feed and we'll
let we'll let hackers hack." uh
engineers do what we do and let's build
from it. So Pal love who is here built
this amazing
uh conference site where you can
favorite things, you can bookmark things
and this is what I use to keep track of
my my sessions for the conference. And
so I messaged him. I said, "Hey, can I
can I use phone this and use this for as
an example for Jules?" And Palv said,
"Oh yeah, sure. Actually, I was sitting
in my last session on my phone and I
fixed a bud a bug using jewels. So, I
thought that was perfect. So, this is
how I would start something like this is
I would go into linear and I would say,
okay, first thing we need to do, we just
heard Scott talk about it, is I want to
add a way to know if this parallel agent
is going to do a bunch of things at the
same time that it's getting it right.
So, first we're going to add some tests.
And then I'm going to actually I'm going
to kick this one off while I'm thinking
about it.
And then using that idea of multiple
variations, I'm going to say add it with
justest and add it with add it with
playright at the same time. And then
we'll look at the test coverage and
we'll choose the one that has the best
test coverage. Once that's done, then I
can go to that other mode of parallelism
and I say I would like a link to add a
session to my Google calendar. I would
like an AI summary when I click on a
description. And these are all features,
but what I'm really excited for is for
AI to do the stuff that we never seem to
get to, such as accessibility audits and
security audits. All those things that
seem to go on the backlog, but are
really important, and I'm super excited
for AI to do that. So, we're going to
also have it do an accessibility audit
and improve our Lighthouse scores at the
same time. This is mostly a front-end
demo because well, I'm mostly a
front-end engineer and it's a better
visual representation, but we've seen
all these all these applied to the back
end as well. Okay, so here's Jules. We
told it to add add tests and ingest
framework. It connects to my GitHub, all
my GitHub repos, and it's going to give
me a plan. That looks about right. I can
see it's going to test the calendar, the
search overlay, the session. That sounds
great. I can approve the plan. So Google
So Jules now has its own VM in the
cloud. It's cloned my whole whole
codebase. It can run all the commands
that I can run and and importantly after
it has these tests. It can run these
tests so it can know when we add a new
feature if it gets things right. So I'm
going to fast forward a little bit here.
And so this is adding just tests. You
can see all the the things it's or all
the components that's it's added to the
test. It's added to the readme. So now
next time that it goes to add something,
it'll look at the readme and remind
itself, oh, this is how I run the tests.
Let's see how it did on test coverage.
Okay, we got down to
looks like about estimated test coverage
look like about 80%. So that's pretty
good. We could compare that with
playright and then we could just choose
the the one we like the best. We merge
that into Maine
and now we're we're off to the races. So
that again it's automatically integrated
into GitHub. We merge that into into
Maine and now we can start saying okay
now I want a calendar link. So I want a
calendar button that can go in and Jules
will work on that. And then sure enough
it ran the test. The test didn't pass
the first time. It makes some changes.
Now the tests ba pass and I can review
this code eventually I could look at
this in Jules's browser but I feel
pretty confident about testing this
knowing that all the tests pass.
Similarly for uh the Gemini summaries
when I click on a description I can get
a Gemini summary. I put this one in an
emulator or I emulated a mobile view
just so you can see I could have done
this from my phone. So this is making
accessibility audit fixing any issues
from my phone. Uh, never mind the
console errors. Jules is going to fix
those. And then I can go back. I can Now
we have this big merge we need to do.
And to be honest, I ran out of time to
finish the merge. And Jules should help
me with this merge. And it's called an
octopus merge. So surely Jules as a
squid should help with the octopus
merge.
But let's just pull our check out our
add to calendar button.
Go back to this
local host. Refresh.
And now I have a calendar button. Let's
test it. Okay. Let's add this to my
calendar to make sure I know to come to
my own talk. And there it's on it's on
my calendar. I could then now again pull
this back into the main branch. And now
everybody at the conference has the
ability to add add sessions to their goo
to their Google calendar along with
everything else that we saw there. a
full test suite, all the accessibility
audits, a lighthouse scores improvement,
and that took me all about an hour and
managing the the parallel process in the
back end.
Okay,
so in theor in summary, the secret to
working in parallel is a clear
definition of success because nobody
wants to review PRs all day. So think
before you get started, how am I going
to easily verify that this works? Again,
Scott hit on this as well. Create this
agreement with the agent. Tell it, don't
stop until you see this or don't stop
until this works. And then a re robust
merge and test framework at the end to
put everything back together and help is
coming.
This is how I prompt for Jules. I give
it a brief overview of the task. I tell
it when it will know what it got right.
any helpful context and then I'll at the
end I'll append a simple broad approach
and then I'll change that last line
maybe two or three times depending on
the complexity of the task. So for
example if I need to log this number
from this web page every day I'll say
today the number is X. So log the number
to the console and don't stop until the
number is X. That was a simple test that
I wrote in. It'll keep going. I give it
a helpful context like this is the
search query and then I'll say use
puppeteer and then I'll clone that task
because I can it's in the cloud and I'll
say use playright.
So again have an abundance mindset.
We're used to working on a single thing
at a time. Easy verification makes it so
now we can work on multiple things at
the same time. Try lots of things as we
saw this morning. Look at different
variations. We can with a parallel
process we can we have the ability now
to try things that we would never have
tried before. Let AI help with those
bookends, the task creation and then the
merge and and test part and context.
Keep using MD files or links to
documentation to getting started doc
documents. The more context the better.
And then we tell people just throw
everything in there. Jules and other
agents are pretty good at actually
sorting out which context is important.
So, more context is better at this
point, but maybe that's just for uh the
Gemini models, which I should have
mentioned. Jules is powered by Gemini
2.5 Pro.
Quick shout out. Thank you, team Jules.
Couldn't have done any of this without
you. If you have any questions, you can
DM me. I'm Rustin Banks, Rustin B on X.
Thanks, everybody.
[Music]